hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within -
part 2 welcome back everybody hello I
hope this is coming to you right on time
it's not late again don't say it's late
because I've gotten a lot of stuff to do
here and we've got to get underway we've
got a lot of radio signals that are on
the horizon and we've gotten a lot of
zombies to show the menu to when we get
to them and then we got to sneak our way
through this whole village and then
we'll rescue our daughter which I still
question very much at this point I am
still not allowed to present sure about
how that goes so bye bye Liam Oh
potatoes okay I'm gonna go over here I
still don't have enough weapon parts to
be able to upgrade everything and and
and I don't have a lot of bullets so I
gotta use my knife as much as possible
track down the source of girls voices do
community know I'm gonna do the thing
where I got to find the other guys and I
got to find a sniper rifle repair part
to this sniper rifle so that we can go
over here and shoot people from a
distance because that would be the ideal
and I imagine I imagine that there's a
lot of things in this game that are
gonna seem like very reminiscent of
Silent Hill because I didn't do nothing
do you want to hear the menu I can tell
you about our specials all right hello
you over there oh no what oh look at me
in the bushes I'm so sneaky oh look at
me oh there you are
geez all right well okay
what are you doing over there is there a
light in that butcher's there's
something that I want to grab all right
excuse me sir sir sir excuse me how is
this not a so I know come on I was in
the bush I was in the fob stuck on a
lamp stuck look okay never mind you know
I'm gonna freak out for a bit here
because that wasn't supposed to happen
I guess when I'm two inches from the
from the guy's face it's pretty hard to
miss me so I can't really be my fault
there all right go get stuck on a lamp
all right we're at it we don't have Coke
is Pepsi okay there you go
got that what a good start to this what
a good start what a good game player I
am oh yeah the ax that's right it's a
one-time-use thing that's handy though
because they do like to grab me oh you
know you know what I could use after
that you know after a rough and tough
encounter with a Zombo I could use a
piping hot cup of joe actually I'm not
gonna go for that because I don't even
know if it's respawn yet I know in my
mind I've been playing this like it's
been 24 hours since the last time I
played this but in the game's mind I'm
an idiot and literally had a cup of
coffee like two minutes ago so not gonna
do that anything in his garbage can
anything in those boxes anything in
those boxes
yeah was that what just happened I know
but I miss mass these boxes up who a
Fu's a cannot be used to repair broken
fuse boxes well then what's the point
what's the point what's the point
I stupid that's stupid there must be at
some point in the game a fuse box and
I'm I know what I got to do I got to go
over here though warden crossbow yeah
I'm gonna go over here and here so
everybody hold on to your pants
geez I'm gonna get to the signal let me
get by these guys over here yeah all
right battle take that take these over
here okay that guy's dead there's a
couple zombies on the rise and there's
at 1k pounding someone away on the roof
over there Hey you all right you all
right no you want a bottle you probably
hit you from here looks like I can't I
got a wicked arm and I could throw real
good that's not what I meant to do
excuse me just wanted to wave at them
with my axe can I ask you a couple
questions I'm good time these guys
tripping on ecstasy or something all
right so I know I can probably sneak
snug this guy don't turn around turn
around I know a lot of all them might
see me sneaks nang'k you but I
I got him I got him I got him come on
come on come yeah it's a stupid desert
yeah keyline is our specialty
oh I'm on fire now that was a mistake
shoulda got my coffee I am very hurt oh
that's not good
I gotta find a bush now let me find my
bush now God please my bush please
please God my bush please wow I didn't
know I didn't know that death would set
me on fire I had no understanding that
would send me ablaze ah damn it I'm all
the way back is there coffee
no I'm not even coffee already god
dammit of such a fool I'm such a goddamn
fool
all right that's my bad that's my bad
that's my bad all right that's not even
a difficulty thing that's just me being
an idiot I should have noticed like he
got fired as an what happened if I stab
guy with fire in hand and I have fire in
hand or mi have fire in face is that
what me em have all right look at this
Oh God do this again do the Oh ow
gotta hide in the bush I just realized
that like for the past minute I've been
screaming my bush my bush please please
dear God my bush and out of context
that's real weird no don't don't do
nothing are you naked
oh god this guy's naked too all right
well don't come near my bush that's all
I gotta say all right well I should turn
off my lamp I'm not gonna make that am I
you gonna turn around before hey I'm
gonna use I'm gonna actually use a
bottle here go right there what was that
oh oh are you I can't believe you right
now I'm not gonna come up with a new
food-related murderers saying is Pepsi
okay it's much less much less
interesting juncture
oh sorry everybody this is off to a - to
high-quality start I thought I was gonna
keep it like a little tepid and you know
my normal like markiplier lowbrow little
sip whatever the hell is going on here
but uh we're starting off with a bag
it's it's it's good it's good it's real
good it's real good so so the lesson of
the day is if it got fire in their hand
don't melee kill them because that fire
will suddenly then be on you and that's
bad and you can't run as well if you
dabble in just that's another hilarious
anecdote all right what was they doing
they're looking for there's something
just right around the corner here so I
should go oh it's a freaking RV no no no
roofie it's not an RV at all that's a
Humvee that's no RV that's home that's
all hum no our god all right no that's
the fire one but the rest of them don't
have fire
so that's see that's literally the only
one with fire so I can I can understand
that if that one came after me then
suddenly they would throw fire at all
the world just kind of ends here look at
all these oh jeez
I didn't notice the corpse at first but
look at all these oh whoa yes it's some
of the weapons that I very rarely used
in the first game this one was
particularly devastating if you didn't
miss and I think I remember I missed a
lot all right most types of warden
crossbow bolts full function as
proximity mines after being fired onto a
surface
Sebastian will not trigger proximity
mines firing a warden crossbow bolt onto
a surface with another surface
immediately opposite will create a
tripwire trap a red laser will aim
showing where the tripwire will be
created
all right the crossbow bolt releases
electrical current which arcs from enemy
to enemy stunning them and sometimes
knocking them down it can also be broken
fired it broken fuse boxes and pools of
water for special environmental effects
shock bolts can be crafted by combining
fuses and gunpowder fallen enemies can
be stomped to finish them off alright
that's weird
okay how did this guy if that vans
a-rockin nevermind oh it's oh it's
trying to teach me oh it's one of those
teaching scenes well hey hey diddly
hummed oh wait how do I get my crossbow
out let me put that three all right I
got and OH
gather all ye gentlemen from around the
world alright turn around and no I meant
nuts ground I'm in that the ground god
dammit I meant at the ground
god dammit why'd you have to catch that
with your face you freaking [ __ ]
alright I gotta stop who you're making
me look so bad I'm not bad that guy just
my aim is too good that's what it was my
aim of Chicago uh hello sir fast we're
not open yet
oh god what an ass I've made of myself
oh what a douche nozzle I meant to aim
at the water I'm in a bush you can't
it's my sneaking bush you can't find me
in my bush get out my bush get away from
my book no no no I'm not in there
anymore I'm in a bush that's right you
better run or walk or step stomp your
stompy legs real real hard when I get
enough brain juice and I get better
sneak in speed oh yeah but no not sneak
in a bush
[Music]
if I hold onto your hats is gonna be
this is gonna be a while
[Music]
[Laughter]
see see this is why difficulty as no no
register I'm currently playing this on
nightmare mode that has no play in what
I'm doing here that is nothing to do
with what I'm doing I will find ways to
screw myself over no matter the
difficulty totally fine everything else
I'm a mess I just want to destroy these
people I want to get their brains in a
jar and I want to move on with my life
oh good thing fire lady's all the way
over there all right well I'm not gonna
waste another crossbow bolt trying to
get that guy down don't look over here
this is my fence my fence cuz the rogue
signal is coming from Crimson's
I believe and that may may may have
something to do with the lovely I could
get you all right you know what
just for satisfaction reasons with my
last crop nope that's no I ignore the
big glowing light over here mister
stumpy foot believe this well back to my
drinking all right
and I just please there that's what I
wanted there you go there you go that's
what you deserve and that didn't finish
him off did it [ __ ] I can't go in there
oh no he did really really all of that
was even what's the foot no come on no
no I don't have a bunch err
don't make me run all the way back don't
please do I you making me
even when I do it right what would have
been the point oh we didn't even follow
me we doesn't even know where I am
to find this van instead
coming over give up all right okay I'm
gonna go this way I know I have to stomp
on them I know that how am I gonna stop
them when the ground was electricity how
how you answer me that riddle me that
audience riddle me that yeah so you
can't riddle me that
I'm unriddle a bull have no idea what my
riddle riddle levels are I'm on Ritalin
no no you know frickin I'm going for it
I'm gonna get up on this ladder I'm
gonna bash that guy no that's slope oh
hello
all right I'm gonna go up this ladder my
back
No oh dude you lost your fire what are
you gonna do now no fire oh this guy
doesn't know everyone he's too busy
smashing all right go angry our mashed
potatoes are searched with onions and
chives all right there we go
got that see you go up a ladder you kill
another Zombo all the others all
missoula oh here we go get out of here
is this like the store owner or
something this is Chad every teen here
in this small town of Silent Hill right
okay is there a reason to come up here
that's the question right is there some
other yeah whoops that's was weird
Sebastian you're cool dude but no no no
what happened there all right climb down
ooh a door you wouldn't think that's how
you do okay man how many Mobius people
were in here and how they all get
separated and died oh no no I don't like
that no
uh why was that so cinematic and scary
why was that terrifying why was that
terrifying there was a specific reason
why they made that terrifying and I
don't like that all right listen I'm not
crazy right like that was terrifying you
guys hearing me right there was
something suspicious about that and I'm
in a the game where I don't know what
everything's doing everything seems a
little suspicious at all moments okay a
workbench I guess sure all right okay I
might have enough to be able to upgrade
my gun or my Stabbin knife I don't want
to upgrade my crossbow that's why I
never really used the crossbow because
why would I use it when half the time I
would screw myself over anyway and when
instead I could be better and do cool
things all right I'm gonna go for fire
power straight up cuz the first one is
worth twenty percent so might as well
blam and then it's a little more
powerful because if I remember correctly
from the last game unless they change
something the the first gun the pistol
is just what I'm gonna be using pretty
much predominantly because I can't be
trusted to do anything else all right
let's make oh I'm almost full on bullets
actually let me not craft those and make
one medical syringe yup our boom bolt I
need sniper parts and weapon parts to be
able to do that but not right now
okay good but also why this was very
scary
it's C it's C I'm not crazy
uh I mean that's that's questionable but
I'm not crazy right this seemed
terrifying so there's something here
okay nothing apparently all right well
I'm gonna go out of this terrifying
place and go over here now boom now that
I know how to do that properly okay so
where was that signal no it was right
around the other side of this building
so it was here there's none of zombies
in my way to be able to cause me a
problem
Oh nails perfect
they make great shrapnel I mean you
could try to build things up with it oh
no no I don't like that
I like the opposite no yeah oh boy I
don't like that
okay I'm gonna no no no no no just run
around no don't don't do the screaming
thing that's that's really annoying oh
oh oh what was that oh why was that
why's that car or rocket
now I'm in a bus oh god I'm in another
bush I'm in a bush you can can't beat my
sneaking bush
oh goodness foliage out of my face no no
no no no no Sebastian that was a cool
bit over but was it necessary this
juncture oh my god they've discovered
the technology of hiding in bushes
they've discovered the technology of
screaming randomly to try to thwart
their enemies which has been my longtime
strategy what's under here let me take
them up and out of my busy day to check
out other's goddamn out No
[Applause]
I hate I hate Sebastian I hate him I
hate him get in my bush no one can find
I'm in this bush now I'm gonna die
because I can't get in a bush why
Sebastian why I know all this is
inherently my fault
ah Frick I'm dead you know no come on
alright let's get a few things let's get
a few things clear here number one
listen listen hang on everybody I know
you're having a giggle right now number
one the whole car rolling thing I didn't
know that was a factor the whole car
climbing thing I'm not used to that
number three that was entirely my fault
that was one percent I panicked it was a
crisis situation I should have brushed
it more calmly I had every opportunity
but number two I reformed sometimes
right at the last second that's not my
fault
they just do that now probably because
it's nightmare difficulty oh that's so
silly thankfully it dropped me off here
and not way back and it's fine it's fine
it's fine just fine I'm tough I'm a
tough tough boy of a tough boy
I'm a tough man see that doesn't seem
right either I'm a tough man I'm a man
that's what I am there we go let's do
this
ring around the Rosie again I like it
all I had to do was get in the bush
getting the bush getting the bush
hey the much in the bush and no not yet
there we go safe in the bush no idea Oh
what happened over there he's just
disappeared
very bizarre no no no no pie oh I'll pay
the bush all right let's not play it
sounds like
yeah
oh yeah okay now I got his number now
I'm gonna take him out to the dance
no no stop the ranting raving I don't
like that yeah I see that was it that
was it uh yeah where you gonna go though
no no no are you going what do you do
stop humping that car
let's give me an opportunity so it's
like when he's like moving around that
he it's only he only like does the turn
doing he really wants at that car no
don't don't no the soup of the day is
potatoes it didn't make sense but I
didn't have a lot of time to think about
it because I admittedly all that time
that I was waiting for you to turn
around I could have been thinking about
her soup of the day but you know I'm new
here I don't know the menu very well
what why who are you where and why what
what were you under the car
is it like secret like the blue glow
beneath the car can either meet supplies
or zombie are those the two choices all
right fine
okay I'll get you I'll get you yeah you
can't see me okay
oh no she's hiding in the bush alright
mistake mistake probably was a mistake
what no she's so fast oh all right fine
geez all right here we go
what an adventure we have here gang what
an adventure alright now that I got this
this is how much effort it takes to kill
one one one dude sometimes alright it's
alright it's alright though we're good
you're good alright so now that we've
had enough time to dick around I still
got to go back and I still have to I
know there's something some item over
there but I'm gonna go around here and
I'm actually gonna get to the signal
over here because the signal the last I
heard from it they were actually voices
let me just run it and give this stuff
that I've earned after dealing with his
[ __ ] a nice brain goo beer thank you
for that
700 you almost I think I need 3400 to be
able to get the sneak in upgrade which
is something very important to me
woah no again you're doing that
cinematic thing and I don't like it oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
my daddy who stole me I was gonna get a
big sack someday and I didn't know what
though well that that ain't right
huh-huh alright I don't like that
Oh again I knew that was there oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh no I have to make the art oh
I made the art No
there we go oh geez Oh
oh geez oh geez okay weird okay is he
coming out this is something else going
to happen why did you set all that up
why do you want me to make art maybe the
arch was supposed to be like me in the
blue actually killing them what is that
all about whoa hello friend what's going
on there there's G to get the who that
guy's got an axe but I'll get to him
later turn around for a second I'm full
of bottles I gotta use my bottles more
so what is this oh whatever was it looks
like they were here oh oh that's what
the phrase off the chain means cuz
you're literally off the chain it's like
letting a dog not sure Oh
I think like I did know that but I never
like connected the dots no stop
I have bottles I'll bash you right in
your freaking head dude no no no I'm
gonna push behind this no no I meant to
be more stuffy about that oh yeah yeah
dad you know before I get my sneaking
speed up I might want to up my like like
oh boy my any literally any other
ability like the quietest run possible
around oh wait I should use bottle
that's right Oh Bush disappeared what
happened to my Bush what what was that
very scary suspicious bottle breaking
one everybody over in house I think I
have enough after this I think I have
enough to be able to get the sneak in
upgrade but before I do that I've got to
see what I'm doing next okay so there's
both resonance points alright well I'll
go north then there was other stuff to
the north that I could have used anyway
there's a lot of axes lying around here
I haven't had to use one yet mostly
because I've been either succeeding or
dying like that's been my two extremes
here but can I go in this place no mobis
lockdown
screw you oh you know I didn't see you
over there I would have tried to help
but I'm an idiot
now I can barely help myself so
Sebastian gonna crawl away I'm gonna do
the castellanos crawl back into this
bush and you can just lay on the ground
over there and die which is exactly what
you did okay so it's right around this
place I'm gonna go the bushy way I'm
gonna go you know what I calling it the
bushy way because frankly I just don't
like when things are called the bushy
way is this a personal prayer no gotta
go the bushy way ah crap get in the bush
hit the bush in the bush I love bush I
love this bush this bush is good mmm
all right I got a bottle Whangdoodle is
behalf my magical bottle push
disappearing powers what's that oh god
[Applause]
no no I thought it was in a bush just go
right there right there right there just
go right there I'm gonna hold this so
this frickin thing disappears no no
[Applause]
I'm unbelievably back this is oh your I
don't trust that this is oh no this is a
trap no this is a trap oh this all is a
trap
oh wow I cannot believe how on
believably bad I've been what no no no
no I was in a bush no no I was I don't
know where you went
please my chance my one opportunity
don't don't chance blow don't miss your
chance to blow don't chance blow don't
taste both ha 11 herbs and spices okay
there we go
[Music]
no no no no I mean I was in a bush no I
was there the boys you know what you
know what sneaky sneaky ain't my style
anymore I gotta hit him in their face oh
stop a dumb them F something oh no wait
Frick ax oh boy
okay yeah yeah there's one down
reload reload reload no no
time to stop messing around I'm gonna
get a little serious even if it cost me
a few bullets here and there there's no
way that I can do stealth kills on all
of them until I get my sneaking skills
up then I'll be able to do self kills on
all of them but I gotta be a little bit
better about this okay so this signal
was right here somewhere yeah because I
don't want to just waste you guys this
time
okay so there's some kind of thing there
Wow
you know in every game I've ever played
whenever I see something like that I'm
like what do you mean you could try you
got guns
Sebastian takes a [ __ ] knife just
that was like that was like a half foot
of steel all bunched up in one easy yeah
Sebastian don't mess with nobody
Sebastian tired of mark Blair you're
giving him a bad name oh that ain't good
you're so close yeah it's so far can I
stab you okay trust that that's that's
hilarious Wow
Sebastian is a bat what's that got my
favorite sports team Go Go Oh score goal
unit basket all right I'll be right
there since you're being so adamant
about it okay I need zombies over here
so if the residents points was in here
some hair so I gotta get in there oh
that a gate open or is that gate closed
okay
all right doesn't see I don't see
anybody out here I wonder if it's
randomized when people are out in the
streets and what people are not I can't
get in this way either maybe through
that door over there but I don't like
these guys laying about
and that just spells bad news bears for
me am i reloaded
I better be I need to make more L god I
do not trust that in the least nope yeah
your eyes are still glowing that means
you're obviously alive and I do not
trust that can I stomp on them just in
case
alright I think I can get in here oh oh
why that trucks are rocking why would I
why would I do that BAM hello and close
that well okay we got someone here huh
are you saying
[Music]
there's a supply cash under here I gotta
get down there yeah I do but what about
all the zombies I'm not too good at that
and I'm lon bullets as as usual my
bullet sack ain't big enough to be able
to take on a horde sure oh maybe I could
like set up a crossbow trap but I don't
have enough crossbows this might be
difficult okay so if I undo all this
panel here
can I like bring them all out I think so
yeah
flip I'm a flip switcher oh I was one of
them puzzles god damn it I hate puzzles
oh I said that does that and then this
oh that's easy
that's nothing all right well this is
probably gonna be bad oh no I got a lift
up what is why does that keep happening
oh oh that ain't good
okay get my bottle out
you seem different oh I don't like that
at all oh that's not good
well that's not good that's that's awful
everybody hush about the know maybe I
could drop a car on him
oh that looks like a witch from from
left 4 dead
I do not address that I don't why is
that that way why are you that way I
don't know no no no no no no no no no no
thank crush you
oh god I don't like how slow you are no
no I don't like it no I don't like it oh
geez oh geez gosh okay I don't think I'm
gonna be able to sneak kill that one
probably Wow no no no I like that even
less
thank God I like you so not no oh I
don't know if that was a tougher one
than usual I hate that I didn't like
that at all
okay all right let's try that again
except this time being less bad oh yeah
it's just panic that kills me panic is
the only thing that's killing me right
now
I just need to stop panicking like a
baby okay there's gonna be one stem
stomps out of there and then as soon as
it does I'm gonna go for it I'm gonna
try to do a sneak kill cuz if I can get
a sneak kill a sneaks not kill with my
sneaking shoes it's gonna be better for
me any day now No
why not what okay all right I'm just
gonna go for it
would you like some wine with your
dinner with your new line oh I knew it I
knew it I knew it I knew it I knew it
your dick no not that you're different
you're different
oh come on hit your target damn it hey
you're out come on hit it
Oh No that's not what I wanted oh boy
yeah you're different okay that one's
very different I don't like that at all
I can't hit my target
boom detective Castellanos oh my god
okay I'm gonna take a medical syringe
that's good I'm out of ammo officially
so I'm kind of screwed unless this
supply cache a blow this has stuff oh
[Music]
this is awful oh why would I do this oh
why would I do this is that the janitor
oh why would I do this
Oh metal pipe oh maybe I can use that to
fix the fix the sniper rifle I mean it'd
be a little ramshackle but I mean at
this point I think it's okay I mean when
everything is a dream world why can't I
just load in some cool cool weapons like
the matrix which this is
[Applause]
okay at first I thought that was
hilarious and then that was horrible but
I thought cuz the two shadows that were
there I thought they were talking to the
guy like the body on the ground like
Johnny get up what are you doing down
there man and then I was gonna laugh and
then I stopped laughing but then I okay
that looks like a supply cache is this a
supply cache oh come on
it's got Mobius on it it looks like a
supply cache why do I got to do this oh
that rat is not having a good time
all right well fine man so I'll go
towards danger it was apparently my
favorite thing to do in this day and age
it was this I don't think I can go
through there and probably not it's
probably gonna set up an alarm if I try
I should go through this door don't mind
me everybody I'm just gonna come over
here Pat this body for [ __ ] hey hey hey
hey come on now hey hey hey come on how
did you know okay that's good well
alright nothing to see here
all right well excuse me you gotta take
this all right why was that what
happened
BAM oh no no no no no
oh that's duh this is the opposite of a
good play go up the ladder
yes ladder yes gasps ladder yes okay all
right we're all good we're all good
we're all good for all gucchi all right
I got bottles
I'm why I'm cause well I've done a lot
of problems a lot of problems a lot of
rough no didn't mean we pick that up
gonna hit that
oh I'm dime dime done zode get up why no
just it's not a matter of difficulties
like I said I would cause by széll my
own problems all right it's all good
okay so is that guy still following me
up
hopefully not oh it arms that okay but
what I can do is I can lure someone into
that or I could just take well all right
that's easy enough all right so if I
just okay just go over there and
hopefully turn around before you
investigate it
[Music]
well didn't do that right anyway no no
oh oh yeah yeah okay okay that's not
ideal what are you doing
everybody hush I'm thinking you've been
at the table too long you have to go you
have to order something okay all right
this ass a bit cuz now is the best time
to do this of course I've got a lot of
brain juice I really need to get this
into my brain like one way or another I
got to get this in me at least I got
some explosive bolts but you're gonna be
good for the crossbow I can hopefully
set up some traps and stuff okay so I
know there's um the way out through
there but there's a deep grumble over
that way but I got to get into that
supply area that's bargnani gotta do
that
okay so I'm just gonna turn this on I'm
a back step [ __ ] in case I cause noise
someone with the port I was about sage
did someone build the fort oh it was
such a fort someone built that fort oh
god I was about I was just about to say
someone hiding in a fort over there and
then boom you got me oh you big dumb
doof all right here's the sitch you're
gonna go right over there investigate
bad noise that was weird huh oh yeah
no God these guys are just [ __ ]
about which way they're pointing rude
[ __ ] in the darkness huh oh you think
you are that's why all right well he's
he going back just for it is he about to
buy start rebuilding is forwardly do I
build a fort in Fort Lee like I gotta
get like the dynamics of this what that
no why did I do that
no that's not what I wanted either oh
boy oh boy did you see me how how did
you see me all right
I got nothing clever to say now huh I've
run out of soup references alright so
got that stupid frickin stupid freaking
fort man over there and then we got
supplies right here yes okay give me
those sweet sassy so this is not a lot I
was hoping there was gonna be like a
plethora of supplies I mean that's good
and all take what I can get I got more
fuses and one not bullets not enough and
I know I can craft bullets on the go I
do but I really want a prioritize go
into like work benches just because of
how many it's gonna like give me one
push push Sebastian you've cut through
like a half foot of Steel with them like
it was nothing no no release it let go
Sebastian you gotta let go yeah I let go
Lilly daughter dead your wife left you
gotta let go man you gotta let go okay
ooh can I get a cold beverage I'm gonna
get a sweet Fuji day oh is that brain
juice oh I forgot I forget that you can
get brain juice out of those things I
don't Aleve forgot what is that over
there
what all right well I'll go over it into
the bushes there's that the tip of the
train tip the train that might be tip of
the train which I like even less but
okay I think that's tip of the Dragon
all right let me make sure I'm reloaded
at least to some extent I think there's
anything down there that I need probably
Oh mmm that seems bad an ominous and
also bad who don't like that okay well
I'm gonna go down this scary hallway and
hope for the best
here we go okay oh boy is bad red goop
red goop red goo red goo bread goop I
need that I need that red goop blood
this mysterious blood red liquid it's
it's like the color blood it's like
tastes like blood oh it really sounds
like blood is warm
what could it be I have no idea oh it's
so curious
oh well life's a mystery sometimes I
[Music]
don't like that I don't like that I
don't like that do people just not know
do people just not know that they have a
voice in their head that they can talk
to themselves with like everybody has
this mysterious like voice in their head
sounds a lot like them but maybe it's
not themselves but you know it works to
the extent that you can talk to yourself
and without saying words out loud I
don't like this
boo sorry sorry I just think but there's
some though
right
okay everything's fine I thought I
thought that was gonna be like an
introduction to another character oh
there's another safe house over there I
could go there I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
back and I'm gonna go hit this one
before I move on because I eventually
got to go over there I will but I'm
gonna go back I'm gonna craft stuff I'm
gonna get brain goop in me I'm gonna
talk to Liam and just in case there's
anything else that he needs I'm gonna
hit that last resonance points because
there's a bigger mystery afoot than what
there seems there were people living in
this city like Union City there were
citizens here but why like that's the
that's the biggest question that I have
right now why were people living here
why did people choose to have their
brains uploaded into a city like I get
that it could have been an experiment
but these people didn't even know about
Mobius like that that person said Johnny
or Terry or whatever was they didn't
know about Mobius why would they have
known about Mobius or why wouldn't they
have known about Mobius when they went
into this thing did they just think it
was just some random collection that was
gonna like let them live out their
matrix dreams because that doesn't seem
right either because if you if you have
to go if you have to go in there like if
you have to go in there there's so many
different things that you could do oh I
got to go back um I will go back to the
workshop and I will get ooh okay I'll go
back everybody everybody hush your faces
I'll get there I'll get there okay I'm
going back but my point still stands why
would the people going into this place
not know about Mobius why did the
technician not know about Lilly
Castellanos people's memory seemed to be
very selective you know what I mean
people's memories are just all over the
place with what's going on here I don't
know if it's intentional or I don't know
if it's like something else there's
there's there's like a deeper level was
it in here in here boom hello hello ah
okay yeah you're right you're right I
think it was back there because there
was a security door that I can get
through now because they first opened
yeah but there's something here right
why wouldn't they know why would Mobius
keep it all secret like why would
why would and mobius has to be like a
big corporation right it's not like one
of those things really never heard of
them that's impossible
Oh was it here ah okay I just miss it
ah any day now any day now that's not a
shotgun that's not oh come on get up the
ladder uh yah yah yah I'm gonna set up a
trap for you
set up a big old trap for you all right
nope too late can't sup trap got a
shootin face
oh come on stupid bullet waste bastard
all right there you go bloap all right
well that's good
got that they got the bolt at least
loaded up with something okay I'm gonna
do explosive rounds yeah yeah she was
she was talking out loud I have no idea
like why why would she what would have
been the point of it yeah I didn't miss
his I was in a bit of a rush here so I
couldn't couldn't exactly take my time
with this all right so I don't have
security code ah oh wait okay hang on
Oh at the door be 34 okay be be 34 so 96
76 Hey okay all right cool cuckoo cuckoo
cuckoo okay that's good I guess
all right what's this medical kit
high-grade weapon parts all right well
that's good okay so does that gonna help
me crapped up the sniper rifle which is
gonna be really good I guess I'm gonna
keep that in the menu here cuz otherwise
I'm gonna accidentally use it when I
don't want to use it but I got a high
grade weapon part which probably gonna
be for the sniper rifle and then it's
got to be some way to get around all
that because where did they come from
right because they went back and then
they came around at me I just don't know
where yeah all right I'm trying to find
the shotgun hang on guys I'm trying to
find it
see this is the other benefit of doing
this live like you guys like do it like
in the comments normally of Let's Plays
like bark you know this thing oh god you
dummy oh shoot and then I cry and cry
and cry because I'm looking I'm trying
guys
I'll try my best I work to please you
but sometimes it doesn't work out and
then you guys are like oh you mark we
don't care what you think and then I'm
like I wanna make you happy and then you
know but here live now you get to see me
cry right on you're gonna see me like be
broken down into tears at my own
inadequacy live in front of you it's all
true you guys are like and then you know
we have a happy fun that's what it's
like that's what it's like every day
where was it I have no idea what you
guys are talking I think it was it in
the workshop
it was probably there probably in the
relationship we have we have it
borderline abusive it's great I love it
it's good stuff all right was it here is
there another one than in here I'm not
going so oh I'm out of stamina
I have no idea where it was was it down
here uh-huh no that's how I got into
that place in the first place where go
back down that ladder break the boxes
you guys I have no idea what you're
talking about
I've no idea yeah there's only so many
ladders you guys look like the ladder
and I went up and down the ladder and
there was nothing so all right wait hang
on you guys we're gonna play a little
game all right just play it's like say
say warmer or colder
let's go through if I'm getting closer
to the shotgun say warmer if I'm getting
farther away it's say colder and all
that's gonna happen is like what we're
called the warmer colder cold it's hot
it's lava lava hot hot okay this is the
only ladder I know mama go down here all
right looking a looking looking I'm
looking I'm looking so hard with my eyes
all right you need meanie miney moe me
me no no ooh ah
that would've been hard too hard to get
an author is Jonathan Stephens entered
unauthorized mobius area in witness
sensitive material
[Music]
Zeta 5 emergency ok warm warmer ok I'm
warm I'm red-hot I'm warm I'm so warm oh
look how warm I am bo baby I'm warmest I
could possibly be so warm of warm mMmmm
so warm cold cold cold cold cold
blinding cold Arctic I'm so cold warm
warmer warmer
cold you're warm and cold mark your
words so warm cold you're cold warm fire
warmer
was it in there for the air yeah
yeah it's no good I'm dum-dum I can't
lava freaking warm warmer warm warm warm
warmest warm cold warmer apparently I'm
warm guys and warm it's not even there
yeah I see this shotguns not even in
this place see ok you don't forget the
shotgun I'm not gonna fight it it's fine
I know is there's no way this girl
I've looked if I haven't found it yet
it's all good it's all good
there's no there's no shotgun here I've
looked everywhere it's not here
let's it's in there which I'll look not
here guys this doesn't exist shotguns a
myth jakka and it's like a dragon you
know it doesn't really exist shotguns
are just the stuff of legends you know
that are our parents tell us about it
wasn't down the ladder no no it wasn't
there it wasn't there it wasn't there no
I'm gonna move on the legacy of the
shotgun shall never be redeemed we've
got other stuff to do though the good
thing I got a lot of time to get this
done or else we'd go nowhere ok all
right now now now all you guys are gonna
be talking about us how hot or cold it
is for like the next 30 minutes straight
I love it
there's like I want bannered of me like
half on fire half frozen just meeting
the fire and ice child you like us
hot like my lower half is frozen to my
hot top half is on fire just please I
need some of that in my life pretty
pretty please oh well hey whoa where'd
you come from how long have you been
following me buddy oh don't even think
about it I'll go up this ladder I will
mess up your day bro okay can't run a
stamina oh he doesn't want to chase Oh
big baby
oh how didn't you get more fire all
right whatever I don't have time to
worry about that I got to go to the
other resonance point which technically
actually I can get to behind this place
anyway
back to what I was saying about this
whole area like I know I'm quick to like
point out game logic flaws but the one
thing about evil within is that it was
it was a very interesting story like it
really had an interesting story it did
have its flaws of course I'm not saying
it was perfect but it was really
engaging and well-thought-out so I don't
want to be like negligent and saying
that these things I'm observing are just
chalk it up to game logic no I want us I
want to think as if this is all meaning
something like you guys did for who
killed markiplier like I wanted dig
deeper into this because something just
doesn't add up I don't know what mobis
his end goal here is besides the control
of people you know what I mean the only
thing the only thing that's been
consistent with Mobius up until this
point is not telling everyone all the
information that they need the control
of information is like the number one
priority of Mobius so this whole system
must also be for that end right like
this whole Union City [ __ ] like
that's all just to control people okay
it's in this house right here this weird
glowing house that looks really lovely
yeah nope okay all right never mind that
there's something over here effing
getting closer what's this my bottle got
a bottle everybody got a bottle yeah so
yeah it's like what does that mean and
what does that mean for me when I'm
trying to find Lily why does it keep
doing that cinematic view I don't like
that I don't like that at all that's
just no good like listen right like of
course if you're if you're suddenly
going into cinematic view in a horror
game that's normally third-person it
spells bad news bears in one day that's
gonna get to me oh good I stole your no
that was flour not smoke powder that was
flour I stole it out of someone's
grocery bag what's going on in here
bottle thank you I don't care if it's
full chuck it at someone no matter what
but that's just a theory I gotta watch
Game Theory's newest five nights at
Freddy's videos I got a I've heard that
they were very good and I've also heard
that Scott Cawthon applauded them now I
think I heard that they weren't exactly
correct but they were about the closest
that could be anybody in here so I gotta
watch this I don't know why but every
time well hello dead body that I was
just stepping on I'm sorry sorry can I
open this no apparently not okay well
what was the point of this Oh
like that at all good good good
I'm never it is
I'm never gonna believe what Turner mr.
citizen murderer I mean admittedly I am
killing these people after and I maybe
I'm not any better than that I am
killing people but maybe they were also
already dead I don't know 100% for
certain which is the true true but you
know oh that's that's strange can I kick
that alright I'll go to the visitors
center I'm gonna get my upgrade I am
that's what the thing is I get
sidetracked very much
I get sidetracked a lot in games but
that's the thing I like about this like
it's just being able to talk with you
guys here is like it's all just it's all
part of the experience because no need
to feel rushed you know what I mean ok
go to the marrow
as computers still working I'm loading
very slowly
I don't that's weird so of course like
this whole thing is a system right
that's why this is explained it's like
half matrix because it's just a
simulation even if it's in in someone
else's brain even if it's in Lilly
Castellanos his brain that all this is
built like that's the whole point of it
like they needed a brain to be able to
join everyone together like but which is
weird by itself it's not it's not just
like oh okay yeah sure they need a brain
no it's it but it's still like it's
fascinating that they can control
something like that and maybe like our
technology isn't gonna be too far away
from that maybe some day I mean I'm not
saying we'll all be living in someone's
brain
y'all can live in my brain it'll be
super fun it won't eat guys we can all
just brain together know like what it'll
be is something even like more than that
maybe maybe maybe not maybe I'm just
being crazy but computers and brains is
probably gonna be thing it's either
gonna be like we're gonna make a I and
they're gonna take over the world or
we're gonna put computers in our brain
we're gonna become the AI technically
cyborg whatever and then we're gonna
multi problem mom just to get
cataclysmic about it but for now we got
cool video games that replicate it
without any of the punishments so
consequences be damned we're gonna go
away are you uh you're one of the ladies
I don't have an axe anymore I would
think that like an axe would be able to
take him out in one go okay so how
should I approach this without being an
idiot
charge blindly forward yeah that sounds
good everybody be quiet
doesn't buy be quiet out there everybody
be quiet
did someone get Jim on the scene so what
should I do
ah blouse killer no what were you going
Sabet where were you going
where where are you going Sebastien them
you freakin douche nozzle
we've got a very serious and per Gert
man your face is so beautiful
I've never seen a more beautiful
whatever you are see is it even worth is
it even worth trying to kill her
like that's that's my question I do not
think it's worth I wish I had my
sneaking skills up oh that's
I could get a shot on her but is it even
worth it maybe I'd have to do two and
then some bullets I know this doesn't
work alright go go go go go go go
no why didn't I go forward no where are
you coming Sebastian Sebastian you
[ __ ] okay let's see if I can get away
from her number one because she's pretty
slow until you're shooting at her and
when you're shooting at her she's really
fast I know I have the crossbow but I'm
trying to save ammo here I'll be all
stealthy about things and stabby you
know tell people about the specials and
such that's the thing right I can kind
of use me just running as a way to lure
her into some places like if I do that
she's gonna hear it right up until I
start crouching right so if she comes
over after that that's yeah so she's
coming over slowly she's coming yeah
there she goes yeah
yeah okay welcome to Dairy Queen so
stressful god damn it I got so much
green goop so much brain juice that
really like gets my heart pounding and
that's cool because the last time I
remember like that much stress trying to
take out mes is like the clicker in the
last of us like that enemy in and of
itself is terrifying but also like
trying to avoid multiple of those which
I know I'm gonna get multiple of these
and eventually I'm gonna have more
firepower and that's gonna be great but
I hope they don't do it too much because
that's really cool like having those
moments where I'm so
laughs okay I take that back give me as
much firepower as I can possibly have
I've got so many parts I just want to
get back to my bench but I keep getting
sidetracked by side quests look at all
these boxes Brown a BAM baby oh this
doesn't sound pleasant why am I going
towards this it's a really hefty
grunting and meat slapping and I don't
know what I don't know what I'm gonna
see around this corner I don't think
it's gonna be good
everybody place your bets
oh he was thrown around the body like a
rag doll
okay Angry Men yeah steamed broccoli
okay can i Pat this guy down oh no that
guy was already past Hobbes Bansky ah
Sebastian's here now what do we have
here hello whoo broken fuse boxes can be
powered momentarily by firing a shock
bolt from a warden crossbow dome okay
sure
let's go that's a normal crossbow I
don't think I have a warden one I think
this is just a normal crossbow I've only
got exploding bolts yeah this isn't
gonna do [ __ ] to it cuz I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure I don't
have yeah it's just a harpoon bolt yeah
I don't have shock bolts so that would
be a waste I'll come back to that once
I'm able to get a craft a shock bolt up
what am i what am I trying to match here
am I trying to match the red okay unlock
what a weird well that's not security
that's not secure at all and kick that
door open Sebastian you know what's good
for you no seems like there's something
there all right is that a gun
take that thank you didn't do you no
good all right god this this looks like
it might be a gun really something good
hey there's the shotgun yoo-hoo you guys
you didn't even know what you were
talking about you didn't even know you
were running me on a wall you didn't
even know oh you were all there it was
all herd mentality one person was like
the shotgun the shotguns in there go
Kenny and then everyone's like Oh mark
you and I I cried for nothing oops
I cried for nothing gotcha
ha ha ha ha ha I'm gonna be that 3:53
that for bombad it ah ok anyway now that
I've been sufficiently [ __ ] about
that kick the goddamn thing open are you
killing me all right also I know that I
can um I know that I can field craft a
shock bolt do I wanna ah you know what
let's do it why not I've got a ton of
stuff let's just make one okay we got
one shock bolt now all right let's do
that
dooblydoo and blank go through go
through Sebastian come on bro get
chopped in half what was the point of
this why did I come here
why did I come here I have no idea whole
Hospital ski Sebastian
hello well I just there's no point to
that there was no there was no point
it's the same direction ah but I'm waste
what a waste of my precious material
ah go god oh god okay get behind
something Sebastian you idiot
oh boy that ain't good oh boy that ain't
good at all no don't oh no indeed ah
Frick okay I must shoot you guys oh
right in the slow T part of your brain
try try me try me brah try me brah are
you doing oh you don't even know where I
am
oh no what what was that noise no he's
not swayed she's not just waged whoa
there we go
all right Amanda I'm missing too many
shots here I'm like my accuracy is way
down but at least I got a lot a bit of
gunpowder wish I got those guys without
taking a hit that's good getting
slightly bad or getting slightly better
but not a lot better but getting
slightly better can this take me up a
man then for you go go oh come on
ah key that's right
oh that's right oh how many of those
have I missed out so many probably but
oh that's right I totally forgot about
the key mechanic when I go back into my
brain I can get the key stuff oh that's
fascinating I totally forgot about that
and you guys probably totally reminded
me about that and I was just being an
ignorant idiot which is you know not
uncommon for me not uncommon at all but
hey I got that okay so I gotta go I
gotta go
I'm gonna go back I'm not gonna waste
any more time I got to go back and I got
to get these supplies in me and I've got
to get crafted up because I got a lot of
upgrade potential but I just got to get
back okay let's go back should I see
we're doing good we're doing good
although I'll take this moment to say
new shirts are on sale right now they
are a sweet holographic pattern they're
available in black and white and a big
logo like this or a small logo that's
just on the pocket they're super cool
love them a lot Oh
you can get them by going to markiplier
comm I believe there's a link in the
description as well they're so
fascinating about the travelling between
worlds like that because you could
literally like they set up these
terminals for the employees to use but
it doesn't just have to be the terminal
like the whole point of this is like you
know you know the whole point of this is
for someone to live out their fantasy of
like the world is theirs to create so
someone can play God like that is the
end objective here they want a world
that's gonna be stable enough for them
to go into and play God where they can
live forever or whatever have you and
they can have a great time all right
change my mind about this immediate
predicament
it gets worse every time I go down that
hallway every single time I go down that
hallway gets worse every time okay all
right everybody hold on to your pants
look closely for monsters oh boy all
right Sebastian Castellanos here let's
try something
howdy how'd you know that was me how did
you know you especially wouldn't have
known if there was a bottle over there
yes yes yes weird thing to say weird
thing to shout when I'm stabbing a
zombie but everybody ignore that just
happened I was very celebratory that I
did that correct please don't take that
out of context that might have been the
most inappropriate way I could have
possibly said like do this weird like
pelvic thrust not what I was intending
not at all not at all what I was
intending but the success is there
nonetheless and I'll own that I did that
I did that good I did that nicely in
fact I could have done it a little
better if I had taken the moment when
the one was stunned from the pull to go
up and finish him off whoa why
Castellanos please I just want what's
under the car oh man some good [ __ ] ahh
why where'd you come from no you know
I'm a weird where did I go you don't
know
where'd I go I'm so sneaky you have no
idea where I am
do you you stupid zombie you stupid oh
oh oh oh that's that's no good okay
nope
okay weird but alright stay on the short
side stay on the short side stay on the
short side oh yeah yeah yeah go around
the corner yeah I might not be so lucky
what are you talking about next time I
might not be so lucky
no cuz jump on him jump on him do
something us all why why why why did you
do that why why I was president Ian's
not F I missed every shot floors oh I
[Music]
did so good I'm why did that go so badly
I was pressing he and not F I was
pressing he and I health
I was trying I was trying I was trying
so hard I was trying so hard I really
was
I was trying so hard I was trying so
hard I shouldn't have been trying that
hard but I was trying so hard I'm so
disappointed like you guys I know you
guys are disappointed you guys are not
disappointed in me because you expected
just that little but I have never like
in any other game like if I flail like
if I flail in panic in any other game
usually I can get by but no other game
other than this one is like anti flail
like I can't flail in Bannack I just
can't I will die every time it's so bad
oh it's so bad oh yeah I apologize for
nothing no what good what no no no all
right you know what let's do it the
old-fashioned way huh by the old
fashioned way huh
full clip huh come on dude you know I
have test out this no oh I didn't switch
to the shotgun resets it
only I could miss point-blank oh I got
him I guess huh all right I don't have
time to wait a second to get back up
kind of run out to see everybody hold on
I'm gonna make it better this time I'm
gonna make it better I'm gonna make it
better I'm gonna make it better I'm
gonna make it better I'm gonna do better
we're going we're going everybody hold
on to your hats cuz I'm gonna rush
through this rush that sounds bad
because if I rush through it then I'm
gonna do terribly but I'm gonna get
through this quickly and efficiently
with no problemo
no problemo up in here we got this you
all I need to reget the key you're
totally right I need to get the reget
the key ah
Everette hold on I got a limp ah I got
stitch in my side I gotta go huh I gotta
get back but hold on hold on to your
hats damn it how far did it go
Oh stupid gay stupid goddamn cake stupid
[ __ ] cake it's a piece of [ __ ] okay
god damn it why did it say back so far
it's been good about it lately but this
one really boned me over ah gotta get
back all right everybody hold on to your
hats yeah I got ya did ya got still on
these just get some exercise
yeah let's do this for Castellanos yeah
can I get back boom that tight ass out
get back to the save us for the past
hour
yeah I'm gonna get there eventually get
a chick yeah all right consoles moving
it yeah Casa let's add a breath Kosmos
ran out stamina okay there we go finally
just get to the goddamn computer got
Solano's all right there we go oh we got
it we got it everything's good
everything's good everything's great
guys
everything's great hey if you wanna go
go go - markiplier comm check out the
new t-shirt by the time you get back
I'll be where I was and I won't be an
idiot
[Music]
running down the hallway doodly
I don't think be to blow is gonna help
me in this scenario I'm pretty sure I
don't think there's a blacksmith in this
town either I don't think anyone's gonna
find a pile of dirt over here very
nothing going on here but I do have a
lot of specials to tell everyone about
if someone was like someone was like why
screaming though and I'm just like the
screaming is my natural response I have
no other crisis response besides
screaming who's stealing its body who
stole it
oh I stopped what oh oh you're really
there you're really a thing oh geez okay
no yeah go okay well you're I didn't
know you were really a thing I did not
know that that's fascinating Wow okay
well what you're saying so that means
there's someone outside of this okay
we're good okay all right now all I got
to do is I just got to get back in good
time and oh wait I forgot to put the
shotgun on three this on four and there
we go you're there there's something
over here
okay Oh God the Dragunov body what the
hell was that
why oh yeah they are holographic the
shirts are holographic they're super
cool I like him a lot I really wanted to
do something special and I gotta say
like the quality of them are super nice
so check them out if you would like okay
all right straight shot back gonna get
this I got it I got it everybody
everybody it's good it's good it's good
it's good
and just because just because I messed
up a lot I'm going to I'm gonna extend
this I was gonna end it like 9:30 but
I'm gonna go an extra like 15-20 minutes
just so I can get something actually
done and that would be super nice
alright so I'm gonna save first
so I don't save any changes that I don't
like blam okay got that go back okay
Liam alright first off Liam how are you
doing oh nothing
missions alright a perk up a copy for me
oh no cup of joe if you don't know this
is the most hilarious healing mechanic
I've ever seen in my life you pour
yourself a cup of coffee you slug that
bad boy back
mmm good fresh hmm all better all these
wounds knife wounds stab wounds bullet
wounds bite wounds nothing a cup of
coffee can't fix hmm right like a summer
day all right now weapon parts I need to
number one I'm an upgrade let's see what
no I'm gonna upgrade let's see what the
shotgun can do 90 for a 5% boost
that's awful animal capacity would
probably be better than that reload time
would probably even better than hammock
capacity would be good
Oh 30 oh hell yeah that's enough okay
high-grade weapon parts I don't want to
do that because I want to repair the
sniper rifle if that is what that takes
30 at 30 is not bad I can do 30 30 s
fine fire rate 40 even that not bad
why not right is that the same for the
other ones too Oh 20 oh that's nothing
all right 20 fire rate good sure why not
at least get the first ones reload time
that'd be good
walking speed while aiming that's nice
but I'm not gonna waste anything else on
that let's see range Church time
charcoal decomposable these guys yeah
I'm gonna hold off all right so sniper
rifle Oh what do you take oh you need
specifically sniper rifle parts okay
that's a thing all right that's fine
okay so I'm gonna make up some Ivy's
gonna give me a bunch not that bunch
let's get like let's get like ten cuz I
am gonna find more shotgun shells I only
have one of seven it's not a lot but it
is what it is just in case cuz I don't
know those are probably good for taking
down down some big guys and I don't know
what I'm gonna find some big guys but
you know it is what it is let's get some
more clothes the bolts are food bowl now
why not just a pipe I guess might as
well go full on explosive but no now I'm
gonna find him well I'm gonna use him I
guess it's all good okay
get more pipe okay so we're crafted up
there we're gonna max out this now I
might find a syringe I'm gonna hold off
I'd rather keep the materials if I don't
need to spend them right away okay now I
gotta put grip brain goop in my brain
and then we're gonna get that I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get my sneaks non conceals
I'm gonna be better at sneakin you guys
are gonna you guys are gonna be so proud
of me I'm gonna be so good at sneaking
oh yeah yeah let's save here - I like
those weapon changes but I'll get a new
save anyway Blanc
okay doodly-doo come on come on
screw coffee use goop juice hey in this
universe coffee is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
indeedy-do nurse nurse what am I gonna
be able to open some lock boxes I got a
key hey could I do that nurse oh okay
excellent some Keys open doors of
perception but this isn't one of them
this one is more mundane but still
useful okay go on open one its contents
I'm better off in your hands which one
do you guys think just say warmer and
colder who gonna swarm or colder I'll
get there I'll get there hang on warmer
I'll call their own for what cold cold
warm that for this one okay all right
cool you got it
Oh gun powder perfect okay let's put
stuff in our brain I like it so much
sneaking skill
oh my guess so much sneak good there it
is yes yes low profile yes grabby yeah
yeah grabby
Oh ambush that'd be really good okay all
right so I need move faster walk crash
oh I need that oh so much in my brain I
don't afford that one but I like the the
ambush skill that's good and eventually
I'm gonna get the predator I will get
that I will get that quickly close on an
enemy oh yes I want that so badly oh I
want all of this okay space near wall
sneak kill
that's so good cuz this I don't need
them to turn their backs yes that yes
yes yes yes yes okay do I need the low
profile number two I mean that'd be good
I do like grabby hands though but I
don't let's just see what else we got in
athleticism and stuff stamina gauge that
would be good health
really factor here okay steady hands
melee attacks do more damage that's
always nice get the ability to push
enemies away from you
recovery though was recovery more health
and healing items athleticism is
eventually gonna be more avoidance
stamina recovery speed running always
good but right now I'm all about that
stealth baby that stealth is gonna be
able to let me get more kills which is
gonna be able to let me you know get
farther to wear it oh I'm all stealthy
baby oh I'm so still stand up yes okay
so like I said I'm gonna keep going for
another like 15-20 minutes just because
I want to test these skills out and I
want to make sure that I don't waste you
guys this time so let's go no don't
avoid it Sebastian come on let's save
one more time because i'ma save the
holic and then we're gonna go in there
it Sebastian it's gonna be good
double save just for just for two for
fun so we got this and then we're good
to go now we can go to the other signal
there was also they said to go to the
visitor center so I'm gonna do that and
hopefully there's gonna be something
interesting at the visitors center for
me cuz Turner said he was over there but
I don't like Turner to move I'm so much
faster when I'm sneaking oh I'm not a
lot faster but I'm faster oh yes I'm so
quiet no you don't see me I'm sneaking
oh I think she sees me no yeah she
definitely sees me okay right but no Ron
Bush bush bush got a guy on the bus
sneaking bush it turns out my sneak oh
oh I think she somehow still knows where
I am
okay good what if I this is not using my
skills to the best of my mood no don't
don't turn around don't turn around
don't turn around
ah would you like a salad with your soup
[Music]
okay that went marginally better but I
don't think it was a factor of anything
other than me being an idiot okay into
the visitors center we go home whoa
anybody here detective Castellanos runny
to take action
I got damn these squeaky doors all right
seeing suspicious in here seems awful
easy actually something in there no way
I can't believe it unbelievable
who's that don't even think about it bro
Turner if you're in here if you're
causing a goof if you're uh kissing up a
goof
I ain't about it not about that at all
well communions ideal mix of a small
town do people know that they're here do
people understand that they're here do
people know that they've been trapped
here like because with beacon Hospital
none of us really like knew we were in
the system we just ended up there don't
go go yeah go I'm going I'm going baby
I'm going lamp what about the lamp
there's something about a lamp lamp very
no lamp here all right okay we're gonna
uh there's a key okay there's a key I'll
get it on the way back there is a key
I'll get it on the way back and I heard
someone say there might be sniper parts
on the roof but I've already gotten this
that might be the other sniper thing I
was that you guys that I got in the last
episode war
oh hi okay
I've recognized this work him again
[Music]
tough luck right tough luck don't rig to
take a picture of the victim that's so
weird
it's so weird it's it's it's interesting
because I've never seen anything like it
before like the moment of death captured
like forever it's horrifying and Awful's
to be art and it's an execution
it's just up it's just a corrupt mind
like another communicator something like
it's so weird
Moebius team members we might have
something useful on them yeah cuz it's
where he's reminding me of was it
Vesuvian Valu V inversion ruvie Andrew
Ian ruvé Ian Ruben Ruben Ruben Ruben
Ruben sandwich Riven Riven some Ruben
Ruby some grooving roubo Rambo whatever
he reminds me of that
no not but oh we go thing I got my
crossbow Jesus and like Reuven in the
last one this guy seems to be able to
like move around like use this place to
his advantage and uh I just realized
what that was sneak mode engaged
I don't like that at all
that's the hell is this supposed to be
sick I know that's no idle boy okay wait
hang on I'm gonna go down the hallway
and get some range on him some range on
him okay what was this about if I put
this on the wall it's a tripwire right
okay let's try that let's try that come
at me bro come on come on right here
bruh that got one of you wait does he
not know I'm here
oh jeez yeah it is let's see if I can
nail him right let's go oh he got up
dammit what the [ __ ]
got him daddy oh come on now wasn't
reloaded ah there we go no damn oh damn
it there we go god I always get like the
first two shots perfect and then I for
some reason miss maybe like really when
their head like loses a bit like not the
question like oh the controller's grim
like maybe but when cuz when it takes
like one headshot in their head like
partially like gets exploded but then
also like a piece of their head is
missing and they got these weird
tentacles popping out of it so maybe
there's something to that where that
target gets smaller it always is Oh God
Oh God all this is horrible
what am I supposed to be doing in here I
don't really see an objective there's
something in here there's some way out
of here
oh they're gonna book shelf sure scene
by the light okay come on use your big
muscle Sebastian use your big strong
muscles
Rubick Rubick thousand Rubik I don't
know I'm not saying this is ruvik but
ruvik like have some similarities but
ruvik also was in control of all of it
this guy only seems to be in control of
part of it so I'm thinking like this
whole system it's more of a collective
than it was before it's more like
unified weird than it was before you
know what I mean the place o'neil safe
house is right there might as well give
him the bad news about his entourage
face to face oh I'll do that okay you
guys said there was a statue in here so
I'm gonna keep my eyes peeled for a
statue where is the statue I'm looking
for you where yeah you hidin you were
buying the counter maybe
in here maybe weapon parts at least
somewhere in here mmm
lamp the lamp I don't see it
unfortunately I don't see it and I don't
want to waste too much time just hunting
for it hey little lady
nope I don't see it I'm sorry it might
be staring me right in the face and I
might be dumb and I apologize for that
but I will get through this game even
without it I tried my best I tried so I
got go tell Liam the bad news everyone
everyone Liam Liam so actually that's
weird because I'm not sure what's going
on with the time like cuz the time of
this place is weird because I'm getting
radio signals from people who are
already dead I'm getting radio signals
from people that may have been dead a
long time
and also I'm getting radio from people
that are here currently like it's it's
bizarre and also the radio is like the
number one thing about all of this it's
it's it's tied into everything and I
don't know I the the radio saving seems
familiar was it like in one of the DLCs
because I know it wasn't the main game
that had the radio saying they're dead
but after what I saw you're better off
without them around they were reporting
on killing everybody in here and now for
one emergency huh can't say it's the
worst idea I've heard you're a real
piece of work on the UM you know that
I'm just being a realist
you can't save everybody it's impossible
mobius made emergency plans for a reason
if they never made this twisted machine
they wouldn't need emergency plans in
the first place
maybe so but look at what they've done
it's pretty incredible still a company
man after all this has incredible oil T
pays off for you at the end because
right now it seems like they don't give
a [ __ ] about you what do you mean they
sent you in here didn't they sorry I
didn't mean to make you angry here I
made some more of these for you for your
troubles he made some of these and it's
like a string of paper butterflies it's
like
he's the enemy weapon parts all he did
was hand me a pile of trash and we'll I
here I made this for him Oh Liam oh
potatoes oh boy
thank you it's beautiful thank you glad
you're taking the death of your old team
so well all right hey I'm gonna leave
all right so I need to upgrade the
handgun firepower
I really do want more firepower out of
this bad boy but at least I know that I
do
oh that's good one percent of 30 I want
that I want the critical cuz I've
already got a weapon part and I love my
pistol I love my pistol pistols like the
like my jam in all of this so I'm gonna
go for the critical that's awesome all
right and let's do a little more
firepower we can afford it why not
blam okay good good to know all right
we're good there Nomi I think I need to
craft some more bullets out of it just a
full clip would be nice okay good we got
a lot of crossbow bolts we got to make
sure to use it I'm not gonna end it just
yet because I'm more curious about how
like I want to get into the real story
this was all side mission that's a
really cool thing about this oh no I'm
out of I'm out of safe slots you only
let me get 10
oh you [ __ ] I want all of it Oh sach
is on the bench outside alright alright
get your get your pants out of your ass
come on stop stop pooping all over my
face Oh God
stop being a dingle donger dingus damn
stop being a pile of poop I'm on it
how long like you guys are persistent
like I got to applaud you about that one
like you guys are persistent so but
that's good that's good bench outside
the church
shei okay oh there it is right oh I
don't know I don't know what it is but
that's hilarious
now I see now I see why you guys were
yelling to be so much that was really
obvious I should have seen oh good it
look boxes let me hop up here didn't one
do time okay I was flying for a bit but
that's all right
pop miss I don't know how I miss but I
miss alright blam I'm stuck there we go
Aries Libra can thing in this game it's
a frickin car physics like jumping up
and down on cars is so funny
alright so we gotta get to oh jeez
shotgun shells ammo ah have got ammo
pouch I can get my sack open up my sack
Oh Papa gonna be so proud of me oh I
always knew knew some damn we're gonna
get bigger Zach oh god today's date
today is good day today is the day all
boy can't load let me look in this pile
of bodies here those things are piling
corpses up here why good question
there's a lot of chat every teens in
here yeah whatever alright see ya gonna
go find me a pouch satchel if you will
and I won't but you will so I know there
was I know there's ombos over here or
whatever those things are they're not
exactly zombies but they're kind of
zombies they were that functionally the
same I guess I think it's in that house
maybe yeah
so many materials Oh Zetas I think
that's a lady I'm gonna call him a witch
anyway just because that's the most
similar thing that I can understand
about that I'm pretty sure that's a
witch witch all which that witch witch
right there any more bottles definitely
a witch don't like that but you got a
lot of goop juice in you and I need that
figure out a way to get around you or
not get around you but get you dead hope
you don't hear this oh yeah yeah you
didn't hear that did ya nah yes lady my
bottle in the trash can
whatever you got another bottle oh is
gunpowder and weapon part oh that was
nice there's nice okay turn off my light
which is don't like light okay so if I
can do the ambush thing they'll be nice
but I don't know if this thing is gonna
be ambushed Abel let's try okay now when
I'm on the short side hold on your
horses
all right 1 1 1 run run run run
sebastian run run run run good good good
good good move good move good move good
move good move good move good move good
move Sebastian thank you boys oh yeah
she doesn't go very far if you're like
not shooting her she really doesn't go
very far oh well I'm in a bush is about
as precarious a situation that I could
ever hope for turn around oh my god turn
around
clicker witch no no no no no oh god oh
god don't god that was so scary
what the hell what the hell hell why
why'd you do that why did you do that
why are you over there now why why why'd
you do that [ __ ] she's in a bush she's
learned to my bush technique I'm gonna
beat her she's in a bush there's no way
she's so smart
I have no idea which direction she's
facing I think she's facing the other
way
mr. back yes okay in the bunch I know
that was just like a bug of the AI but
what the hell what oh hello oh it's fire
lady like that fun just throw that on
that wooden building and just have fun
there's a way to get up the roof over
there I'm gonna get that but this might
be I'm not sure if this is the ammo
pouch or see a moped please didn't I see
him about you she stole my bush
she got it yes I got a satchel Oh
finally
oh that's I mean finally I've already
gotten to in this episode alone which is
good all right what's in this house um
what's up actually let me look my
inventory
there's shotgun shells and the other one
over there would be good I need to save
my shotgun shells for the big boys
bottles a lot of shopping that was done
over here quickly
first aid medical syringe I knew I was
gonna get another one of those yeah
there's so much benefit to be able to
explore know that okay good god oh god
no
okay
boom Gosselin's don't open doors slowly
that's not how Castellanos operate diary
I don't like the cinematic I don't like
it I don't know no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no finally entry
of this diary penned in an unsteady hand
there's something in the house with me I
can't see it but I could sense its
presence I don't think I want to see it
I think any of those horrible things
outside they're everywhere I'm afraid to
go out there but a prince and her too
I'm shivering but it's not from here why
did it why did I go in this house why
did I go in this house it's freezing Oh
God oh no oh no no no why did I go in
the zone
[Music]
Oh God okay all right that's fine that's
fine that's fine that's fine it's a lamp
it's a terrifying lamp by hey dad oh god
oh no no no oh no no no no no no no no
thank you
no I don't like that okay I'm a run now
I'm a run running is a good idea
I'd like running run for me no no
kidding I gotta get out of here no
really oh I gotta get out of here Wow I
got ya ah don't you Lala around me lady
oh don't you all know I don't like you
okay how do we get outta here through
that door okay maybe that door
you don't obey physics oh it was just a
random house that I went to do I didn't
even have to go in the house I just
chose to I made a horrible error okay so
when in that door which means what
exactly
it's Diamond Jim
it says it's non-stop this demons Jim
Damon's Ron Jim has gotta be some way to
get out of here okay yeah no I'm getting
to it okay I'm getting to it
okay that was noisy all right so she
went in that room and I guess I gotta go
in that room doughnut I'm hearing a lot
of Lala's coming out there I don't want
to go into lala land over there you know
what I'm gonna be brave boy I'm brave
I'm brave I'm brave and I kicked all my
doors open yeah that was a mistake okay
hate that oh hey you died and I hate you
okay all right
Hachiko no no she's coming this way
she's coming this she's coming this way
okay she absolutely is coming this way
okay rollin her freaking stabbed her
with my knife oh no she's going No
oh my god
I can't go in there
ah the big [ __ ] baby up god I just I
can't thinking she's right there
maybe I just gotta go in come on brave
everybody hold on to your gyms we're
going in she's just walking away okay
now's my chance okay so walking around
that corner I just got to go for it I
gotta go for it that's all there is to
it
good thing I up my sneak in speed okay
I'm in here is good maybe I don't know
I'm not on a percent sure maybe there's
like a key card or something in here
here garden no damn I've been [ __ ]
okay all right but this way through here
good all right
I'm bowing around but it's all good
okay I'm brave okay where the heck I
know it's got to be in here right it's
in here it's got to be in here a lot of
these tourism
okay oh wait there's a there's a picture
painting that's me that's my picture
painting sorry I'm whispering this might
get me out of here
that's a beacon that's a beacon that's a
beacon hospital security guard why is
there a beacon hospital see
okay
[Music]
I've never hated anything more because
usually when these scenarios happen
there's like deep thrumming music and
all I've got is these Lala's okay fine
okay all I need to do get around her I
need to get enough distance between her
and this door for me to be able to use
the security card yes yes yes yes okay
she's through there that means I can do
the security card and I'm Audi I'm Audi
baby I'm Audi yeah casually I'm gonna
kick it open to BAM that's how
Castellanos operate oh wow my head oh
boy yeah I remember all that did I just
imagine that was that Jojo that was what
was that thing was that real or all in
my mind
on the table that was either me I
thought it was Castellanos at first on
the table then I thought I saw glasses
was that Jojo on the table there there's
no way there's no way I was so fast
I couldn't tell but I I don't know it
went by so quick I have no idea if it
was or not it probably wasn't and I'm
crazy
I haven't even I've totally forgot about
Jojo I mean what happened like in the
other one is Jojo died was that Jojo
there's no way okay
anyway I'm gonna get back real quick I
got a photographic slider and to get to
a safe house there's no way he died he
was like dead dead and I like mourned
him I don't know it's hard to say what
am I looking for wait where am I
actually there's another safe house up
ahead I'm gonna get to that one first
daya easy-peasy I'm gonna get to the I'm
gonna get to the other one first there's
no way I mean I'm probably crazy cuz why
would they why do they bring him back is
the real question that's probably
shotgun shells over there but I need to
get to the safe house I'll come back for
other stuff nope don't like that okay
that's weird
Oh can't climb over this okay well why
was that doing oh well I okay Wow okay
nope didn't no no no no no no no let's
not do that
all right let's not okay we just got to
get it a safe house and I know I'm Chris
what is that up there what is that no no
no no I see the safe house I see safe
house my god oh god it's locked off why
is it locked off some kind of like oh I
need a shock bolt cuz that's that's got
to be like a transformer right cool okay
take this shotgun shells now again
you're doing the cinematic view and
there's zombies on the ground over there
I don't like it okay whatever she wants
okay so if I open this oh cool it gives
me one right here perfect okay so yeah
that is locked off so if I just bolt it
with a shock bolt
hello how's it going in here ha no no no
no no no ah I got you babe all right
cool what's going on here he was working
on his car I just saw you working on his
crime okay I don't like the safehouse
anymore
something tells me I don't want to be
here at the safe house something tells
me safe house is bad news bears
bad news Brummel bramble oh okay anyway
[Music]
we're saved so there's a lot to wrap my
head around but unfortunately I'm all
out of time for this episode but worry
not I'll be back at 8 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time tomorrow for another
livestream this will be posted
immediately after for anyone that missed
anything so don't worry at all you will
see everything if you miss something
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down the
comments below but you've been doing
that as I've been playing then it's been
great so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
bye bye bye guys bye goodbye bye bye bye
bye bye bye